if i'm able to take the thing i have the
most fear for
or the insecurity that's been triggered
or the imposter syndrome that exists
and i'm able to name it and represent it
before
it can either be weaponized by someone
else or weaponized by the voice in my
head i'm
able in some ways to dismantle it and
and actually ask like
is this real my strategy in the short
term is
focus on the things that will move the
needle most first
in real time i'm focusing on like in the
next 30 to 90 days
how can i best honor the intention of my
creator in a way that keeps me on this
journey and
serves the audience really well come on
guys we need to stand on youtube
come on this is fantastic
hello what's up my friend mr dave paulus
in the house
hi evan carmichael i'm doing well buddy
how are you
good guys if you don't know dave author
of get out of your own way
this is the advanced copy that
you know you know what i love about you
i mean like you were religious about
posting
your takeaways from the book which i dug
but you also
read at a pace that i don't understand
you like
just take your time reading a book and i
i love that though there was something
beautiful about like oh
you're still in it dude i'm a slow
reader
i'm a slow reader and i read seven books
at a time
one on different days of the week so i
don't know it's it's a weird system but
it works for me so i had i forget what
day of the week because i went through
this i mean it's
it's got it's got notes and stuff and
yep your dog ear marks
i didn't want to do too much because i
know this is the advanced copy you know
i like it the you know at the back is
like uh just blank pages where it's this
is where acknowledgements are gonna go
so i i love the kind of sneak peek this
is just an idea man
when we met in puerto rico it was just
like an idea it was just an idea we sat
around a table
talking about what it could be and then
a year later it came out and now a year
later there's another book that
is coming out so it's crazy ooh what's
the new book coming out
oh i have another book it's called built
through courage
and it's coming it's not until october
so we'll bludgeon people with
conversation
around what built through courage is all
about but it's this idea that like
we all live for the most part inside of
a place that we have become comfortable
with that i would describe maybe as the
safe harbor
where because of maybe having a little
bit of fear
because of the way that we've just
become connected to
how it feels to be inside of that
familiarity even if it ends up meaning
that we are
settling for suffering that we know
instead of pursuing something that might
look different
we do so because we're afraid of what
different might look like
and the whole conceit of the book is if
you are willing to face your fear
you have an opportunity to cast the
vision for who you hope to become
and understand the things it might take
to get there but it starts by just
acknowledging a little bit of where you
are
and why you stay connected to the
structures the stories the limiting
beliefs that have kept you
anchored to this doc that we you know
often find ourselves living inside of
dude that's it i love it man through
serve i started through courage built
through courage
my book is built to serve so that's why
i get second i guess come on
so built through courage nice that's
right
and october october 26th
are are you are you coming to our
september meetup
heck yes i am what are you talking about
i wouldn't are you bringing do i get my
advanced copy and softcover or something
100 you're gonna get that so you're
gonna get that early version we're gonna
sit down and have a chat about it we're
gonna chop up how we can
uh use this thing you describe every
once in a while youtube what is the
youtube i still have not yet figured it
out but
what are we dave hollis needs to be on
youtube ladies and gentlemen
what is our youtube strategy dave what
are we doing honestly
here's the thing i i'm like in a little
bit of a restart mode so
i was the beneficiary previously of
having humans that had expertise
inside of the social space generally and
youtube specifically
and as i am like in a 2.0 version of how
i'm going to try and pursue
offering value to humans and serving
people with the work that i do
i am a team of one well i take it back
i'm a team of one
and another so now there's two humans i
have a person named susan who's amazing
but
just the two of us are now trying to
figure out like what does it look like
to try and
scale something from scratch after
having had something that previously
lived inside of
an ecosystem with support so my strategy
in the short term is
focus on the things that will move the
needle most first
and uh unfortunately for me uh youtube
has not necessarily been at the top of
that list but it needs to be that's why
i need to like hang out with you man
okay
it's gonna happen people in the comments
says dave 2.0 is fabulous
i love it i agree dude are you still
doing i mean i remember you're doing the
ig lives and you're running
and and coaching people and bringing
people in is that still part of your
your plan still part of it yeah i mean i
we just finished today we did a little
30 day move your body challenge
it was very simple like if you were to
commit for 30 days to 30 to 45 minutes
of body movement
tracking what you're fueling your body
with and then trying to find the
connection between
movement and fuel on how it makes you
feel whether it's energy
or mood or something that you know like
is i i was
myself tracking muscle composition um
that like just doing that inside of the
community was something that was
a fun thing a free thing trying to
encourage people to show up for
themselves and hopefully in doing that
show up better for the people that they
love
the most um but i'm i'm working on
i've got this non-fiction book that
comes out in october there's a tea time
book based on this thing i do with my
daughter that comes out in february of
next year for
kids i am doing monthly coaching inside
of growth day
and have a podcast and rise together
that happens every thursday so
those are the things that i've been
working on in real time but like
building out a new website that's a
thing that will happen in the next
couple of months building out a youtube
channel the thing that will happen in
the next couple of months but
um it's all fresh it's all new i mean i
am in the like last six months nine
months
i've really been kind of looking at a
bit of a blank piece of paper and trying
to decide what i want this next
version of how i can serve people best
to look
and in a crazy way like i've been a
little more deliberate in taking time to
make sure that the things that i am
creating will lead first with service
and will hopefully be
tools that if people were to implement
them like afford them some life change
but that also
i would wake up in the morning and feel
super passionate about it they're like
super super excited
about it and so i think that's one of
those things where i didn't want to rush
it
and there's some good dividends that are
paying off for taking a little bit of
time to figure out what it is
honestly i would whatever you're doing
on instagram
all your ig lives i would just straight
upload them to youtube
okay that's a good place to start like
no editing
just put it up just as because it's
better than nothing
yeah and a lot of it is i think what
what makes
dave hollis so awesome is just the raw
you know it's like hey this is me here's
what i'm going through here are my
struggles here's what i'm excited by
and people just feel like all of these
are just basically all of
all the insecurities dude like one by
one and here's another insecurity and a
lie i told myself and here's how i
so i think that's i mean that's really
your brain it's not just the
everything has to be perfect and i'm i'm
the perfect human it's the you know i'm
i'm
really just like you and so totally
normal human yeah like
i mean you're freakishly tall that i
mean that that is besides that
i am freaking freakishly tall i've been
cutting my own hair in quarantine sorry
about that everybody but i did find that
better than better than no hair dude
well i mean you're handsome thank you
um i'm actually i'm sitting down with
the publisher for
this next book release tomorrow with the
marketing team and then like actually
laying out like okay well how do we
create something awesome for the presale
window and how do we get people excited
about the fact that it's actually coming
out and youtube is on the agenda
so i will take your advice i'm going to
start putting things
up in on a channel that already exists
but has zero traffic and i've never done
frankly almost anything to promote the
fact that it actually exists i know i
have to i just haven't
yeah just i can give you an entire
youtube strategy
we'll talk about that in september let's
dive into it but yeah yeah but for now i
would just honestly like whatever
don't over complicate things just post
whatever you post on ig
you post to youtube if you're going for
a run and you're just giving some
inspirational talk that's a youtube
video
it's vertical it's not going to be
pretty but it's better than zero
and inside thought leadership your ideas
are badly
so your ideas are badly needed that's
why i'm always so pumped to
dave wallace is coming out this is great
let's you know
how often are you how often do you post
like inside of your channel right now
how many times a day are you putting
something up on youtube
youtube will post across across all of
our channels
20 to 30 times a day holy cow
all right you you have more than a
single human named susan clearly
yeah that's amazing yeah yeah yeah i
mean we have 35 people on the team
um but on the main channel we do once a
day
we've done once a day uh total videos on
the channel
including unlisted is ten thousand
something um
so it's pretty it's pretty crazy but
i've been doing this for a while right i
mean april 2009 i think was my first
video so it's
it's been a couple minutes that's
awesome i mean i'll just i want to
acknowledge
courtney in the comments is suggesting
in real time that this is like a cool
thing to watch entrepreneurs that like
kind of get together work together
whatever and i will just say for anyone
who
doesn't understand the genesis of how
you and i
sitting around a table right like we
have had the benefit of being a part of
a mastermind for lack of a better word
where a bunch of us
get together have conversations and the
strengths that any individual person may
have that they can bring to the table
end up being a benefit to every person
who's sitting at the table and evan
certainly has as a
superpower in this planet youtube
strategy and has i
i mean god bless you has been trying to
beat me over the head with how i ought
to also implement some of the things
that he's been advising on but
if you as a listener currently are not
surrounding yourself with people that
are better at certain parts of the
business
or the life that you'd hoped to live
then you are
sitting in the wrong circle and so like
finding a way to sit at those tables
even if they are virtual circles right
like even just like sitting inside of a
conversation like this
maybe affords you just a little bit of
insight or like the permission to
post in the way that evan is trying to
encourage me to post i don't even know
what it is that
has kept me from posting the thing is i
i'm so much of an open book most of the
time
i think it's just that i have a little
bit of a story that i've told that i
don't understand
youtube well enough or that i don't know
how to do it and so since i don't that i
shouldn't until i could do it really
well
and that's ridiculous i understand that
it's ridiculous as it comes out of my
mouth and yet that's still a story that
i'm trying to confront
it's it's so important because it's
still the only place where your content
lives forever
you know that that post that you put up
today that video in five years you still
get new
attention traffic awareness versus
instagram twitter all of it
disappears like a week later nobody
cares um and
and the stuff you talk about is so
timeless it's not that it's this is an
only june 2021 strategy
you know the stuff you talk about is so
timeless that um anyway i just think
your voice is needed dude
and i would like to i would love to see
it uh and and if you start
whatever just whatever you post on
instagram post to youtube
and then obviously videos and then we'll
look at it in september
we'll look at it and i'll i'll then give
you a better longer term strategy but
step one is just
just like everything else step one is
just start no the thing i think when i
was with you last that like
had my brain explode just a tiny bit was
your
your ability to show where in a video
someone
dropped off and where in a video someone
rewound to hear something again
and like the trail of breadcrumbs that
those insights might be
for how you take that part of the video
the one that they rewound
and actually use it as a part of
marketing inside of something
pay attention i mean i paid attention
now if i could just implement the thing
that you told me but like i love
the idea that like man there's there's
like real-time
insight available your audience is
telling you the things that are sticking
and maybe even more importantly the
things where you've lost their attention
and if you can use that information to
make better videos the next time or
like rework the thing that already
exists into something that might be
marketing to
just deliver more value it's just like
it's so good
i just got to go do it well listen we're
starting to do it on growth day
for brendan yeah and then and we're
going to share that with the speakers
too so i know i've shared with you like
one of the clips that you did on growth
day but even inside that 10 minute clip
there'll be a moment from 2 minutes and
32 seconds to 4 minutes and 18
that hey if you cut this for an igtv
video it has the highest
so we'll start sharing that with with
you guys as well when you're ready to go
but
but yeah starting point just post dude
people need your money
post post so what so what where are you
now with the thought leadership stuff i
mean
you're this is your first right
so now now he's now he's doing the
annual book thing
he's doing the growth day stuff he's
been he's been a coach
he's been a speaker he's getting his
youtube channel going what
what's what's the what's the plan what
do you what are you moving towards
well it's interesting because i i mean
the the tagline or the subtitle of that
book
has the word skeptic in it because i i
think i identify
as a skeptic in some respects even today
as a person who
is immersed inside of and has been the
beneficiary of a ton of growth that's
happened
as my own growth journey continues and
so
i don't know i think like if i were to
think about like who am i or what my
brand might be
like i'm probably going to be someone
who's a little more
honest about the way that i still
struggle or the way that
in like having a breakthrough it
probably came
inside of a space that was uncomfortable
and i wasn't you know necessarily every
single day
proud of necessarily and so um
i don't know like that to me i'm just
i'm trying to figure out how to serve
an audience best by staying true to the
experience that we all share as human
beings and so
if there's a way for how i've processed
divorce in the last year or how i'm
approaching
pushing myself in a triathlon in july or
an ironman in september like
those kind of things like i still have a
lot of fear around a bunch of the stuff
that i'm going to do but there is i
think some universalness
to the way that each of us might
approach pushing
into an uncomfortable new space and so
um
when i think about like well what role
do i play inside of thought leadership
or i mean i don't even like the word
necessarily but like
inside of the work that i'm doing
currently i'm trying to show you
a little bit of what my journey has been
in the hopes that there is
relatability to it and in somewhat of an
empathy bridge that might be created
in explaining some of what i've been
through that if there were a tool or a
trick
or something that i was able to use that
helped me continue on this
never-ending journey of becoming that
maybe you can use that same kind of tip
or trick to
help you if you're stuck get out of
stock if you're
already on a journey and growing to even
grow further and dream bigger and
achieve even more
so i don't know my short-term most
recent
question that i've been asking like i
truly believe that every single person
who's listening to this
you and myself we were created with very
intentional
deliberate design that there was this
thing that was thought out by our
creator for
who we each could be and so the question
i'm asking right now in real time is
like how can i honor
the intention of my creator in the way
that i'm doing the work that i do
and trying to serve the community of
people that i spend time with every
single day
and like i'd love to give you an answer
that like oh that means
i'm building x y or z like in real time
i'm focusing on like in the next
30 to 90 days how can i best honor the
intention of my
creator in a way that keeps me on this
journey and serves the audience really
well
come on guys we need to stand on youtube
come on
this is fantastic you know when i first
met you so when
i mean in puerto rico was that 20 was
that 2019
no 2020 it was like no it was 20 20 19.
2018 or 19 it was early yeah 2019. okay
so when
when we all met when we all got together
i mean i didn't even know who you were
really
because because you weren't you were
yeah because
because because you're not on youtube
you don't know who i am and i had no
idea who you were
yeah and what i loved like one of the
first things that you said when we're
kind of going around the table
introducing ourselves
and for people watching now this is a
pretty elite group you got
brendon burchard there and dean graziosi
and jay shetty and
a woman who just sold her business for a
billion dollars
jamie kern lima who you all know now and
all of these super high-level
entrepreneurs
and the first thing that you said was
when you first got invited to the group
you felt like you didn't belong here uh
it's like big imposter syndrome like
what am i going to contribute to these
guys and it was the first
thing that i thought too because my my
tagline is believe i'm trying to
solve the world's biggest problem people
don't believe themselves enough but what
am i going to go teach brendon burchard
about belief i
just feel like oh my god why am i even
here yeah and but i didn't i didn't have
the
you know built through courage i didn't
have the courage to say that and it was
like the first thing out of your mouth
like i like this guy i don't know who he
is but he's amazing
so is that is that a conscious thing for
you that you're trying to
like whatever insecurity or kind of
feeling right now i just want to
get it out there to the world yeah
what's interesting is
and there was even like a little part of
this in that last book where
if i'm able to take the thing i have the
most fear for or
the insecurity that's been triggered or
the imposter syndrome that exists
and i'm able to name it and represent it
before
it can either be weaponized by someone
else or weaponized by the voice in my
head
i'm able in some ways to dismantle it
and
and actually ask like is this real is it
is it a thing that i am allowing to
manifest because of having given it
weight
or is this a thing that is bs that's
just
ridiculous that plays on something that
happened when i was younger or that like
has been triggered any time i find
myself in something new
and by sitting at that table and owning
it
in front of a bunch of people whom i
respect i mean frankly some of whom to
be honest
i didn't even know but to start in that
place that represents hey
i am here in a posture of humility
looking for you with the expertise that
you have in a space that i do not yet
have
any expertise i'm interested in learning
as much as i possibly can
and i want to make sure that i set a
little bit of like
front loading in some ways an
expectation that i
know i have enough self-awareness to
acknowledge that this is where i'm
starting from
and in that i think that the like
willingness for anyone at that table to
put their arm around me and say man i've
been in that place
i also recognize when i was you know at
that point in the journey
i also felt that insecurity or i also
felt that imposter syndrome and what i
needed more than anything
was for someone like the people at this
table to say hey
number one it's normal suit like just
normalize the fact that these feelings
exist and number two
here's some tools and tricks that worked
for me when i was there
that you might be able to deploy inside
of your own life to change the way that
you're feeling
about the challenge of walking into and
trying to conquer something that's new
and so um i mean i i talk about it in
the last book
when i when it came to negotiating big
deals inside of the entertainment
industry
when i left disney i was the head of
sales for the movie studio
i got the job when i was 36 i had no
experience relative to the people that
were
on my team and no experience relative to
the people that were sitting across the
table in negotiations
and to be able to engender some trust
with the people on my team
hello i don't know as much as you do
so i need one some permission to ask
really dumb questions so that you can
make me smarter about this business that
i am trying to lead
number two i would often say you may
have believed yourself to be a better
candidate for this position
than me and guess what on paper i
wouldn't even argue with that
but let's just acknowledge that that
exists and
figure out how i can best serve your
interests and how you
in supporting me might allow me to be
the best kind of leader
for our collective mission in achieving
our goals when it came to the
negotiations right we're on the other
side of the table
often i was afraid that somebody on the
other side of the table was going to
represent my lack of experience or how i
didn't understand the way deals worked
and so i would start the meeting by
acknowledging
look i don't have any idea how deals
have worked historically
and you guys have so much more
experience than i do but what i hope
that it might create or afford
is some objectivity that allows me to
think differently
about mutual like mutually beneficial
deal making that isn't encumbered by the
way things have always been done
now immediately right i've taken the
poison out of the thing that they could
have weaponized against me in the
negotiation and
opened their mind to the possibility
that that objectivity could be a
resource
and not a liability and so like it was
good for me
it was hopefully good for them certainly
when it came to the people on my team
it connected us and that they were like
oh well at least this guy doesn't drink
his own kool-aid or think that he
has more experience than me or is going
to tell me what to necessarily do
he's trying to actually pull me into
his world in a way that stays somewhat
more humble
and and acknowledges then and has some
respect for the expertise that the
people i would depend on
actually had of course i needed that i
couldn't done the job without them
do you know what you're going to ask our
mastermind group in september
the weird thing is i asked the same
question three years in a row
and now i think i have to ask a new
question i mean like three times in a
row my question was
just because you can build it should you
just because you can
should you and at the time right
scaling something that ended up like
there was a lot of success
it was happening at a fast pace it felt
like
it might compromise some of what
i had as interests for lifestyle some of
what i had his interest in relationship
and so like the conversation that ended
up happening around
that big question just because you can
should you
um it was so helpful because now as i'm
back at
square one and i'm trying to construct
what it looks like in the future my goal
is not empire building my goal is
creating something that would like
affect
the way that i might be recognized by my
adult children
20 years from now at a birthday
celebration the way that
the video that plays at my funeral might
recognize the legacy that was created in
the back half of my life
now might an empire be built i okay
maybe as long as it doesn't compromise
the way that i connect with people that
i love and show up well for my kids as
long as it doesn't change the way i feel
about myself when i'm by myself
maybe but i don't know that i have that
as the primary question necessarily
anymore i think i have a pretty good
answer just because you can
i don't know that necessarily you should
i actually think
i want to stay focused on how can
i best deploy the light that was
afforded to me by our creator
to give that light away to the people
who are in need of
whatever it is that i might be able to
afford them and so
um that's why again like i'm pacing
myself just a little bit in focusing
on writing as good a book as i possibly
can and what comes out next in
really focusing on trying to be the very
best coach to
get the community inside of growth day
but i also have taken on
just a small handful of one-on-one
coaching clients
i mean i'm not even charging them in
real time but
i'm doing it because of the way that it
kind of fills me up and
fuels me to see if it's a thing that i
actually want to go and do full-time
like to expand it but um i don't think
we spend enough time
dipping our toe in the waters of things
we haven't necessarily tried before
before we jump completely
full force all in and the the idea of
kind of like playing with your
curiosities to see
which of your curiosities develop into
passions is
such an important and undervalued thing
that i have just
man i've just like really been spending
time with like is this the thing that
when i wake up in the morning i'm like
yes
i am on fire to go do this thing like
when i see
that i've got my hour-long meeting with
this person
where i'm i'm working with someone named
mindy right now and she is
a world changer and she is like trying
to step
into the world changing possibilities
that exist in her life and i just i have
so much affection for her
and her mission in this world and when i
see
that i've got that time on the calendar
with her i'm out of bed i'm like yes
this is why i'm on this planet i feel
great about the way that i am honoring
the intention of my creator and having
made this
a deliberate decision for how i'm going
to spend part of my day today
i want that you know like we can spend
our lives doing
pretty much anything but if you're
waking up every day and you're not on
fire for have passion for the thing that
you're getting up to go do
what is this life
so do you know what your question is
going to be this year i don't yet know
what my question is going to be
on the plane right over you're going to
figure it out i'm going to figure it out
no i'm going to spend more time than
that
i i have adopted this
ritual now of trying to
spend a couple of days disconnected from
technology
with a notebook in some place of nature
and my time to do that happens to
just precede our time in uh where we're
going
in september and so i am i'm gonna use
the time
because what i've found is like there's
so much noise
in the world that when we are encumbered
by
all of the distraction competing agendas
other people's
needs or or whatever it might be even
just like messages from marketing or the
incessant nature of news using fear like
it's really really hard just like to
uncover what it is
that you are here for in the next six
months or two years of your life and
i'm gonna go sit on this rock in the
middle of nowhere out in tucson arizona
and i am going to with my open notebook
just right and it's not like the prompt
is basically
what's like what's in your heart what's
on your mind what is that like what is
your intuition telling you
to spend time on and i'm going to come
out of that and i will have my i'll have
my question ready from there
i love it what we got thank you dave and
evan i think this video gave me the
perspective
i needed i love it you're getting so
much
that's why you got to be on youtube this
video should go so this is going to be
on my youtube
for people who watch the replay we've
always got a live audience here but
people who watch
the youtube replay where do you want to
send them to we'll probably get a couple
hundred thousand people watching this
where do you want is it the book is it
your instagram where do you want people
to go
i mean i spend most of my time on
instagram i mean instagram
and uh and facebook but like instagram
mr dave hollis is my handle like that's
probably the place to
hear most about whatever it is that i'm
thinking on any given day
and i'm gonna obviously like in stories
and in post direct you to whatever ends
up coming
my my website to be honest it's almost
done
but i can't even send people necessarily
to it just yet because
there's nowhere to go but hang out with
me on instagram it's the place where i
think i feel most comfortable and
probably share the most of what's on my
mind
all right youtube check the description
below we'll link that up go follow this
man get ready for his new book when do
pre-orders begin
there the weird thing is they've already
begun but we haven't
actually announced the cool incentives
that you get for doing it so
okay um i think they officially
officially will kick off with a bunch of
great
coaching stuff that you'll get for free
july 28th
okay build through courage get ready
great
be dropping soon it's coming thank you
dave appreciate you man uh
all always all the love energy the
perseverance the courage for you to show
up and
can't wait to hang in september right on
brother i look forward to it thanks for
having me on today
much longer all right take care if you
want to see my last one-on-one with dave
hollis check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there we're here for a
single reason put tools in people's
hands that
let them change their life i'm going to
fail just a little bit every day because
i continue to push myself into things
that i don't know how to do